[Musique]
m est en tournée dans toute la france
avec une nouvelle facette de son
personnage mister mystère fin de la
période rose début de la période noire
et blanche désormais m papillon
gangsters et chante des textes sexuelle
[Musique]
charlton foule
pas du sensuel et sexuel parfois je suis
plus masculin que gavant de france
sait pas ce que ça veut dire mais avant
c'était ce côté je suis plus sommes
peut-être un peu plus aux hommes que il
ya 5 6 ans il aurait donc fallu trente
sept ans et matthieu chedid pour devenir
un homme fils de chanteurs petit-fils de
poétesse mathieu grandi dans une famille
d'artistes où il se définit plutôt comme
rêveur que comme acteur
[Musique]
j'étais un enfant très spectateurs de la
vie qui qui est beaucoup dans le rêve
dans le rêve de ce que j'arrive de ce
que j'aurais pu être jeté dans d'angola
dans la perspective parce que j'allais
vous de ce que je pouvais être et donc
dans le fantasme dans le rêve pourtant m
je trouve sa voie d'eau à 12 ans il
passe ses week-ends dans la maison de
campagne des souches en a fumé débit 10
à jouer de la guitare et à côtoyer les
amis musiciens de ses parents
le des clip musical guitaristique goût
là vraiment il ya quelque chose qui me
fait dire qu'il fallait que je fasse ça
pue sérieusement c'est la rencontre
david mcneil qui m'a lui a pris 3,4
accords fondamentaux est
hélas une porte s'est ouverte ce simple
à partir de là la guitare est rentré
dans ma vie et est devenu
un compagnon principal pilote après
avoir été guitariste matthieu chedid
décide de se lancer
[Musique]
afin de se démarquer de son statut de
fils de vider le choix de l'excentricité
et s'invente un drôle de personnage de
scène il le nomme m
[Musique]
elle est impressionnant c'est clair déjà
à la base c'est une des rares l'aide
fois fable
je suis
un prêt par la suite à ces plus récents
je me suis rendu compte aussi depuis
l'enfance c'est quelque chose qui me
suit
et on a su hibou dessinée dans bernard
but faire en noir et blanc d'ailleurs
qui est assez incroyable et je me suis
rendu compte déjà bien plus tard qu'il
m'avait inspiré un peu mon personnage
quand je regarde ce hibou aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement un vrai mon coin
circulent il a la coupe de m je me rends
compte aussi qu'il est fatale semaine
quelques pas pour moi
[Musique]
disent que tu sors
à tel point d'ailleurs que ces dernières
années m a bien failli dévorer mathieu
en plus d'être devenu une entreprise
faisant vivre une centaine de personnes
elle m'a fait de mathieu un personnage
public paparazzi et désiré quand on veut
ce métier là c'est des métiers comme
très ouvert aux autres ça c'est plutôt
génial mais on peut finir a en tout cas
par le sentiment d'appartenir à tout le
monde l'idée on finit par se poser ces
questions-là de se terminer je fais tes
parents je me recentre un peu parce que
justement c'est très très ouverte où ça
s'est un peu il faut se protéger un peu
parce que c'est pas pour un seul homme
ça fait peut-être un peu beaucoup quoi
alléger retrouver
au mali ma liberté
alors mathieu chedid a eu besoin de
prendre le large de se remettre de sa
rupture d'avec audrey tautou de se
libérer de ses obligations de chef
d'entreprise bref de faire le vide et de
se recentrer sur sa vie d'homme
[Musique]
même si toi tu crois que c'est quand on
vient père qu'on peut devenir un peu
plus sommes aussi c'est très liés
puisque c'est avec l'idée de la
responsabilité l'idée de l'ajustement
d'état qui peut pas être un homme femme
enfin je veux dire un père femmes il ya
vraiment une fois être un homme quoi
pour être père c'est un apprentissage
promet déjà d'être père et puis de
devenir non en même temps un homme alors
je sais pas si je suis un agent n'est
jamais fini complètement 1 mais en tout
cas je verrai cinq ans
un album est donc un retour à lui et
c'est avec sa famille qu'il a voulu
enregistrer ses frères et soeurs à la
musique son père au mixage sa compagne
juliette deschamps à la réalisation
c'est complexe et famille donc quand on
voit que il est possible de deviner des
choses de créer en famille sans que
c'est surtout rassurant on ne peut pas
tricher je me dis pourquoi aller
chercher ailleurs alors que c'est la
face à moi c'est en fait c'est plus
l'idée de de transmettre afin de se
rendre compte que les choses sans son
sont juste là quoi alors pourquoi aller
chercher à quoi côté puisqu'elles sont
façonnés
[Musique]